Matt: The 2020 NFL draft is in the books
and we're going to take a look at the top
five classes from this year's draft.
Matt Miller and Connor Rogers.
Connor, I have to start with the Baltimore
Ravens seems like they do this every year
they make history drafting the first ever
player from LSU and Patrick Queen for the
Baltimore Ravens fractures that never done
that before but also they get JK Dobbins
and leak Harrison both molho state Justin
might have bouquet the interior pass
rusher from Texas A&M Devin du
vernay a speedy receiver out of.
The Ravens were the best team in the AFC
last year until late in the playoffs the
players.
They added a truly believe they're looking
at the Kansas City Chiefs and saying try
to run on us now.
Oh and we have our own speed
receiver that can score some points.
Connor: Yeah.
I absolutely love what they did Matt.
I'm gonna go with the team that who knows
they could even run into in the Super
Bowl.
That's how good they
look on paper right now.
That's the Minnesota Vikings and when
they came out of round one with Justin
Jefferson who had no
business falling for them.
I was really excited then.
They got Jeff gladney after
trading for more assets.
So I think when you look at what the
Vikings did they were able to replace the
van digs, they were able to find a
starting corner for Life After Xavier
roads.
I think Rick Spielman is a guy that knows
how to play value in the draft and he
knocked it out of the park
these last three days.
Matt: Absolutely.
Did it reach Spillman again?
One of the best drafters in the NFL that
turn that roster over consistently love
the speed that they've
added to this roster.
Another came out a lot of speed.
Oh my goodness.
Buckle up Las Vegas because it's about to
get fast Henry rugs the fastest player in
the draft.
You can't hang around one Damon Arnett
tough-as-nails inside corner from Ohio
State, but then Lynn Bowden Brian
Edwards Tanner amused you get an interior
offensive lineman and John Simpson a lot
of Clemson players in their counter, but a
lot of power and a lot of speed.
I think the Raiders also surveyed damn see
West and said, We better be able to score.
We're both better be able to make some
explosive plays and they get some guys who
are defensive chess pieces
in our net and Muse.
You can move all over in that secondary.
Connor: Yeah, it was super impressive.
I mean, they also got a starting slot
cornerback in a Meek Robertson in the
fourth round towards the
end of the fourth round.
So the Raiders.
Attacked value needs and they weren't
afraid to double dip it positions.
Either to get more points on the board.
Now.
I'm going to go with
another AFC team here.
And this might be the obvious because
they got the first pick out of anyone.
That's the Cincinnati Bengals.
But what they did after taking jobber.
Oh Matt, I'm pretty excited.
I think T Higgins is another really
good Above the Rim Target for jobber.
Oh, we don't know how much longer AJ
Green is going to be there t Higgins and
jailbroke coming in together.
Building that connection.
I think it'll be fun for
those guys to play together.
And then you look at the two linebackers.
They were able to take later on and
Logan Wilson the productive starter and
three-year captain from Wyoming and Hakeem
Davis gave your from App State when you
look at his ability and
coverage outside linebacker.
He can Blitz those guys are productive
players that defense quietly needed a lot
of help in the middle of everything and
they were able to grab two starting line
backers later on.
All
Matt: right, one more team.
We got to give Jerry Jones credit for
the drafting his Dallas Cowboys hat.
They surprised us all by taking CD lamb in
the first round, but you have to applaud
the bravado go get another receiver with
Amari Cooper and Michael Gallup already
there, but then around to they checked off
arguably their biggest need with Trevon
digs Corner out of Alabama.
They get Neville Gallimore to
play that three techniques.
On the interior out of Oklahoma and then
in day three they just kept hitting hits
Reggie Robinson Corner out of Tulsa.
Tyler be - a senator from Wisconsin
Travis Frederick just retired.
You might be relying on this guy and maybe
my favorite pick the entire draft for the
Cowboys the last pick of round five
Bradley Anaya powerful pass rusher from
the Utah Utes.